les débris de la carlingue se mêlent aux
voitures calcinées l'immense incendie
provoquée par le crash chez le carburant
de l'avion a gagné 5 des 9 étages de cet
immeuble plus de 2000 m², 17
appartements sont partis en fumée il y a
esclaville ou cet écrasé l'avion est
situé au bord de la mer d'Azov juste en
face de Mario Paul seuls les appareils
militaires sont autorisés à survoler la
zone depuis le début de l'invasion en
Ukraine en février dernier
le département d'enquête militaire de la
commission d'enquête russe a ouvert une
enquête pénale sur le crash d'un avion
sous koï 34 dont la ville de yeah dans
la région de Krasnodar des spécialistes
légistes du bureau central ont été
envoyées sur les lieux les enquêteurs
militaires sont en train d'établir les
circonstances et les causes de
l'incident
selon les autorités le sukkoi 34 un
bombardier de l'armée russe aurait été
victime d'un problème technique lors
d'un vol d'entraînement l'un des moteurs
de l'appareil aurait pris feu au
décollage les pilotes ont pu s'éjecter
avant que l'avion ne s'écrase sur ce
quartier d'habitation au sol les
recherches sont désormais terminées 13
corps sans vie dont ceux de 3 enfants
ont été retrouvés